today's topic
why men
say they want to use only fans and so i
did a bunch of interviews with guys on
instagram if you guys aren't subbed you
guys should definitely go to our
instagram because we do a lot of lives
we'll bring on fans and a lot of guys
came on admitted why they use it deserve
so what did you want to say about this
topic actually i have to blame you and
preach for this one you have to blame us
yeah because here's why because i was
watching an episode of you guys about
your episode you guys and you was
talking about this female who act like a
dog
so i had to do it no no no
[Laughter]
no
this man blamed us no don't blame us you
saw that [ __ ] you said it was kinky that
you wanted to get in don't blame us
thank us but don't blame us [ __ ] yeah
both of you [ __ ] are playing
she should thank us you should thank us
too she got a new subscriber
you you
whatever you got your rocks off it's a
girl who walks like a dog yeah yeah yeah
yeah i know exactly what the [ __ ] he was
talking about so he said maybe she does
okay so the girl who like pretends to be
a dog
he's like she definitely has an only
fans so this man said oh [ __ ]
i can't resist anymore i gotta look this
up on only fans let's go see if she
really lives like a dog so when i found
that i was i described himself for one
month
one month just because of what y'all
guys said yo
bro i love i just want to say i love
your content y'all make me laugh
you know
we're not gonna stop back there brother
nah
he's out here watching a girl [ __ ]
jump into a kendall and pee like a dog
and you're trying to make it our fault
that you're into ladies
you're gonna blame behave like [ __ ]
okay that's you no it's not us i'm gonna
just say this bro you can't blame me
i hear about a lot of stuff online and
you know what i don't do i don't go
paying for it i know it exists i know
there's people out there [ __ ] horses
i don't go be like where are their only
fans out
nah that was a wild bat though that was
a while back i don't remember when i'd
be honest with you bro
her doing the dog stuff how good was
yeah yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
do i admit to this
how good was it
hey okay yeah
so what's your thoughts
i forgot about that
that's good all right that's good so all
right what's up what's going on what's
going on yeah man i called him before
yeah um
me and my wife use it to uh
find other people
for our interest
so i mean
that's like yo yo you'll hit up people
who are on only fans that you guys think
are attractive and then try to involve
them
okay i respect that
his honesty and [ __ ]
yeah i resented this was my first caller
of the day so yeah okay is it effective
very and safe
okay go on you have my attention i'm
listening it's verified i mean
a lot of these other websites um
but with a smaller one that people make
they make you want to pay for them
okay
uh
i don't have to pay for it i could just
go on your videos and if i like you then
i just call you
because you're willing to do the video
anyways
oh so they get to record it for their
content
and you get to
introduce somebody new into the building
it works out
hey you know what listen you're out here
rubbing your hands like birdman nobody
won't say nothing to you i'll be
watching your videos
i gotta give it to the man because
everybody who hears about why would you
pay for it his monkey does get it online
for free and everyone's looking at this
[ __ ] right now like i'm mad at it all
right yo this motherfucker's ready oh
yeah so i do that because that so then i
don't have to pay for it
say something me my wife and chase a
woman say something say something hey
man yeah that's what i thought uh why
but what about diseases listen these
women get tested way more than random
hookups on the street yup okay be honest
with you going on tinder is a much
bigger dice roll than going with
somebody who actually gets tested all
the time one two
a lot of times
you guys talk about only fans and
they're like i don't understand why guys
would pay [ __ ] ships anybody who pays
for this is [ __ ] stupid it's just
free online so instead of just having
that kind of rhetoric i thought it'd be
really good to hear from the guys
directly why they use it so yeah the
question is um why do you pay for the
only fans like i kind of wanted to just
let you kind of speak a little bit then
i asked you a couple questions okay sure
um so i found it from reddit for the
most part um like there's tons of reddit
subreddits of people advertising and
stuff like that um i think my initial
point of it was um
trying to get a more personal connection
um
but when it came down to it
it really wasn't necessarily that and um
like i i've in and out paid for it i'm
not paying for it currently but i have
before probably will again
um but sometimes the uh stuff that they
offer is a lot more like personalized
than um standard porn could be
honestly right so you feel like there's
a bit more of a connection between you
and the person creating the content
i did at one time i don't necessarily
think that way about now did you um
throughout your process did you get
these people to do custom content for
you
i never did no i always kind of felt
like that was like one step too far for
me personally i'm not sure yeah i just
don't i never really like there were
other people in there who said oh yeah
i'm really active in my dms and stuff
like that and i never really got into
any of that sort of thing okay so can
you just take me back to the time when
you first initially started you said
something interesting where you felt
like you felt like you had more
connection with the person that you were
um
watching can you can you tell me a bit
more about that like
um why did at that i know you don't feel
that way now but why did i that time did
you feel that connection
um
you know it's it's kind of the same way
that you would like support a content
creator on youtube or something like
that it's sort of that same thing where
it's like you like the work that they're
putting in on one's platform and so you
decide to follow their patreon or buy
some merch or something like that
um so i just felt like you were
personally investing in their future and
the content they put out do you think
the sexual nature of it makes it
different though i i wanted to know
for me personally it doesn't really feel
that way if i had if i had a friend that
um i thought was attractive and had it
only fans i'd probably subscribe to
theirs really
yeah i would personally yeah that's a
good question
that's a great question because it does
it's like what you said before
the minute we put sex into that thing
change that changes everything oh no now
it's not good but you got [ __ ]
on my patreon and stuff like that
because it's scx that's a big no right
but it's content
it's content consuming yeah you could
some of you can uh go on this
page and get it for free you get the ads
or whatever if you don't want the ads
you get on you you know what i mean yeah
some people go on the patreon just to
get bonus footage right so some people
like that proximity to their content
creators now
listen i want everyone to approach us
with a bit more of an open mind rather
than just being like these guys are sims
and all this stuff try to do some
listening try to like understand what it
comes from listen i'm not trying to say
everybody go open up the only fans i'm
encouraging this keyboard i'm not into
it never paid for one it is what it is
but
i did want to understand the mindset of
people who did and rather than come at
them with you know animosity and call
them sims let's try to like listen and
understand do you understand
just to kind of support them and whatnot
yeah yeah yeah it's just like i would
follow my friends twitch watch their
streams i would watch their youtube
videos stuff like that do you do you
support a lot of like youtubers and
patreons and stuff like that yeah yeah i
do i probably have about
anywhere it kind of goes in and out but
30 to 50 on patreon a month so this is
really interesting for me so do you when
you so how do you pick somebody that you
would want to support who doesn't only
fence and what is the criteria for
judging like a youtuber shares opinions
that you like or they make content that
you enjoy and sounds like you know when
you watch them you learn something
insightful what is it about like the
people you choose on only fans that
you're like i want to support this
person
uh it's it's kind of interesting uh you
know
the the part that does separate into
like only fans content from youtube
content you know i watch youtube content
because i like their opinions i may or
may not like the person you know that
kind of goes in and out but you know i
support the content they make with that
sort of thing it's somebody that i
actually enjoy with only fans like it's
somebody who like i could see myself
being friends with this person or i
could see
um
i can see myself with this person in
some cases i try to stay away from that
sort of mindset but i certainly fall
into it
you kind of
you know like we haven't done it even
with women who are out of reach we
imagine ourselves dating them or
sleeping right right right
the same thing okay okay that's
interesting that's interesting
yeah i had to tell my bank what only
fans was at one point yeah yeah they
were probably confused they were very
confused that six-year-old ladies at the
bank did not understand
and that was a well articulated point
the way he did it and we
proposed it in the answer to that so
that's
that's a good conversation there i'm
gonna save my commentary for afterwards
yeah go ahead uh i'm gonna raise the
question to you that i i said was why do
you pay for the only events
uh well it's
it's kind of a once a month kind of
thing i don't have like a bunch of
people i subscribed to it would be like
only one person a month
okay and um so you got one that you
subscribe to tell me about that
yeah like well it varies from person to
person just to see like
like i'm not gonna say like i'm not
going to say like that oh i
there's a personality or something like
that they're hot
like uh yeah
that's it like many people i come across
on tick tock actually
and you're like i want to see more what
are they doing
like twerking are they sharing their
opinion
they're just
there
opinions intelligence content they're
just there yeah i think when it comes to
this only fans rise i think one thing we
have to admit to ourselves is a lot of
people out here are lonely
a lot of people are seeking connections
okay this is not a website
no it's season arrangements
well they got arrangements all right are
you admiring that arrangement
so
you bastard so
you know due to that loneliness i think
a lot of people are seeking for that and
you guys might say go outside go a lot
of people are indoorsy they're
uncomfortable with the opposite sex i
think this
desire to pay for this only fan stuff is
just a symptom of that because you even
heard like some of the guys that came on
and there's a kind of reoccurring theme
throughout the whole life where they're
saying essentially like you know i liked
her i thought she was cute i could see
myself being friends so they have these
like parasocial relationships that are
almost closer to intimacy than
with other creators right so
i'm sure people do this with all the
youtubers who are females right so
there's always that relationship that
starts to build between people
kind of women do that with me
they like pay for content try to get
closer to me like i'm like i don't know
right so just understand that
when you guys are calling these people
and you're saying all this stuff all you
do is like you stigmatize them more i'm
not saying we gotta caught all these
people and say good job but understand
what they're dealing with is just a
symptom of one hypergamy and two just
the current dating market a lot of dudes
are getting priced out just not having
that much luck and so they turn to these
things for affection or or more interest
and you have to understand you know and
and you know on the opposite end there's
some ladies just turn to instagram
they just activate their instagram and
they get all that feedback so you know
anyways go ahead you have to understand
this also the climate that we live in
there's some people that might not
necessarily want to approach other
people like that it's
become somewhat
difficult and touchy yeah for some
people it's very
you gotta fall into a certain kind of
box to be able to walk up to people and
then all to work there's a lot of things
that you have to check and you have to
have a lot of awareness not everybody to
have that but they have enough awareness
to know that they don't have that
awareness to talk to people and approach
people without being seen as creepy or
this or that so it's very
it can be very complicated for people it
can be very
yeah it could be it could be complicated
so they just use whatever they got to
use with that comment and then you know
the covet the fact that we some of us
had
curfews and confinement
the anxiety level increased with some
people so just going out there is
creates even more anxiety so of course
that yeah that doesn't help shout out to
these guys for coming on being honest
and being forward about this because i
know a lot of people would know
otherwise shame them for it yeah
definitely um and even you could tell
they felt a certain sense of shame for
what they were doing so obviously for
some folks it's conflicting emotions but
um what i would say is um another reason
why some people do it is maybe what
they're into you can't easily find on
the internet and also the fact that it's
personalized makes the experience much
better so who am i to tell people that
they can't spend five bucks a month to
get like
personal feed picks that they can get
off to you know that for some people
that does it well you can just google it
yeah well it feels more special when
someone sends it to you the same way it
feels more special for you when your
creator responds to your dm
it's not that different i think just
because it's sex there's a lot more
taboo and weirdness involved with it
but you know it's really not that
drastically different i could definitely
understand how people like personalized
content
i know because i run a patreon
so
i think when it comes to this
conversation rather than yelling at
these dudes i think we need to focus
more on the idea that a lot of people
are just lonely
a lot of people just want connection
and if this is how they're finding it i
wouldn't go and stigmatize them further
like we need to figure out a way to fix
that loneliness so that people don't
jump towards watching a twitch streamer
for 20 hours or
watch
some grand only fan for five hours or
whatever it might be you know maybe if
we give people better balanced lives
they'll be less likely to engage in
behaviors that they themselves don't
necessarily enjoy
so
um that's my kind of general thought did
you answer that that's pretty much it
all right well if you guys enjoyed this
video you want to see more like this you
want to see us more interacting with
fans on like difficult topics and
bringing videos leave a like and a
comment tell us what some suggestions
you guys have
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]